now Garth Brooks is calm he's gonna be
out here in just a couple of minutes but
first
well Andy and I want to get something
out into the open you know we tried be
pretty honest on this show and I think
this is important to talk about as you
folks probably can imagine we spend a
lot of time together Andy and I and as
anyone knows if you work closely with
someone problems and issues can come up
well recently there was one thing in
particular that had the potential to
destroy our friendship and I think we
have a pretty good friendship but this
was bad oh yeah it was pretty rough and
I'm I'm just glad that we we got through
it you know when we worked it out yeah
past it yeah so and what we did it was
it was important that we resolve this
problem so Andy and I did what any
mature people in our situation would do
we took our problem to Rolanda she she
is a true talk-show Queen she helped us
out a lot she was invaluable and so
anyway we have a tape of our appearance
and if it's okay we'd like to show it to
you right now I think this is kind of
part of the healing process for us Liz
could you roll could you roll our
rolando appearance please welcome to the
Rolanda show everybody most of you
probably know my next guest from his
hilarious late-night talk show yet from
what he tells me it's not all laughs on
the set these days let's find out what's
going on behind the scenes ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
we are so honored to have you we really
are
[Applause]
bounine hi things going you've got a
great show or things going well for you
they're uh they're going pretty good I
guess
aren't you getting great ratings I mean
the wonderful guests are you really
doing well yeah the show's for the most
part going good I understand though that
you are having a problem with someone
you work very closely with Rolanda it's
out of control
it's my sidekick Andy I don't know
what's gotten into him well Andy's
backstage but before we bring him out
let me read to the audience just some of
your concerns in the letter you wrote me
Conan and I'm going to quote here since
Andy has been working out he's a changed
man after each show is taped he can't
wait to rip off his suit and parade
around our offices like a show pony he
feels the less he wears the better
I swear lately I feel as if NBC stands
for naughty boys club
[Applause]
melanda I know that people who dress
this way always lined up in trouble
please help me get my Andy back
well Conan I mean if things improve
since you wrote this letter Rolanda
frankly they've gotten worse really well
I think we should bring Andy out here
don't Jude aren't you wondering well are
you ready to confront Andy about this I
think I am all right well Andy come on
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Andy Andy I've got to admit I don't
think we've ever seen you like this
before you just heard Conan you heard
the letter that that he wrote us I mean
what do you have to say to him he's just
jealous because I've been working out
and I look good
he certainly does feel good it looks
like yeah well you know he makes me feel
sick
Frank well now now now Conan and in all
fairness let's hear Andi side of the
story Andi we're listening well it's my
turn to talk don't shove me all right
I'm gonna shove a shoving this is so sad
you are just jealous because I've got a
better body than you do anybody has a
better body I have the better body
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how did this resolve anything I a night
that just occurred to me looking at it I
felt so good until I just saw that I
think you and I still have a big problem
all right screw it we have short
attention all right we'll take a little
break when we come back Garth Brooks is
going to be what is going on